I'm a lifelong RC modeler I grew up
reading about NASA and the test pilots
here you know check that you're breaking
all sound barrier and it's a little bit
surreal to actually be here now flying
on the same lake beds
it's really amazing and certainly a
dream come true yeah my name is reg
ensign I run the subscale Flight
Research Lab here at NASA Armstrong
Flight Research Center walk into Red
Jensen's workshop and go to model
airplane heaven the planes here may be
small but they often lead to big changes
in the way we fly on earth and in space
so we use small scale unmanned aircraft
to test out theories and ideas before
they go onto the manned world the lab is
working on ways to send rockets to space
more efficiently it's tested life-saving
crash avoidance systems and a little
something called the lifting body this
lab has been in existence since the
1950s with a guy named Dale Reid and
Dale Reid is most noted for pioneering
the lifting body concept or the wingless
re-entry vehicle he was a model airplane
guy he did model airplane stuff for fun
on the side
he built a stick and tissue model of a
lifting body and proved that it could
fly and started showing his peers around
here and the idea sort of stuck and it
grew into a full-scale program that
eventually gave us the Space Shuttle
liftoff of space shuttle one way NASA
innovations are often tested out by the
subscale lab these days red and his crew
are working on an experimental wing
called the prandtl but how it works is
the way that we twist the wing so in a
normal wing the high and the low
pressure mix off of the wingtip and you
get a Vorta see a horizontal tornado of
air that's high energies tightly
constrained vortex and that's exactly
what the winglet was invented to
constrain with a non elliptical lift
distribution we shed the vortex earlier
about 3/4 the way out on the span so the
vortex sheds here is it's more open and
loosely constrained the design could
make wings as much as 11% more efficient
and it could someday be sent into space
too
this eventually will fly and land on
Mars that's what this is intended for
when we visited the subscale team was
working on a new concept to launch
rockets more efficiently so what we're
doing here is developing a new aircraft
it's an unpowered glider and it will
also be unmanned here we go guys yep
that'll carry a rocket payload
underneath it and will be towed by some
other aircraft to an altitude where the
glider releases from the tow aircraft
and then it releases the rock and the
rocket heads off into low-earth orbit
rocket launching traditionally is very
expensive for lots of reasons you're
tied to a ground-based launch complex
you're tied to a weather window with an
air launch you're free to roam wherever
you want it's much more efficient a
traditional vertical launch you burn up
30 to 40% of your fuel just getting in
the first several thousand feet off the
ground where if you can air launch you
can save all that which relates directly
into more payload into space or less
fuel for the same payload building
cutting-edge aerospace ideas in
miniature
makes red shop a pretty popular place at
NASA Armstrong the full-scale pilots are
up and down here telling me I have a
cool job and I find that pretty ironic